jetzt kommt live für dich von maria
laach deutsch 3 2 1 1 in diesem moment
drei megawatt motiviert denke ich bin
mal lustig scheint selber schwer
mein vater ist am apparat okay okay
leute geblieben herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heutigen video leute
spielen wir bisher mit dem google
besitzt herum denn jeder kennt es
selbstverständlich die kugelblitze
verkackt einfach besetzung das sind
einziger sinn es sich dafür da richtig
zu besetzen sondern ist dafür da falsch
zu versetzen damit spielen wir heute
super und wir schauen einfach mal was da
für verrückte übersetzung haus kommen
jetzt auf die ganze geschichte mit
google besitzen funktioniert
folgendermaßen leute wir denken uns
jeweils eigene sätze aus diese sätze
dürfen maximal sechs wörter lang sein
und dann packen wir sie in den google
was derzeit und übersetzen sie einmal
rund um die welt 66
das sind als 45 das übersetzen jetzt
einmal bieberstein moratti dessen was
man von martina zoom übersetzen und ja
dazu haben auf fünf wörtern habe ich ihm
gesagt warten viele meiner hand knöpfe
verlinkt ich hört ja nie im kino pur
mein hemd hat viele köche und jetzt 40
erste und da machen wir als nächstes
doch mal russisch auf jeden fall okay
als nächstes passiert mir hier wertmäßig
schnee das sprechen wir zu viele wie
wäre es denn mit ich bin okay leute
wir werden für das abendessen zu spät
bringt junge natürlich habe ich das
natürlich
wir werden für das abendessen zu spät
wir kommen zu spät zum abendessen
ich verstehe dass die 116 vor
es kam einfach gerade mal von der
haustechnik herein und meinte so ja
übrigens hotel nebenan hat eine austritt
von chlorgas und ich startete heute
nacht er hat nicht gesagt er hat gesagt
wir sollten auch die fenster zumachen
aber hatte mit nachdruck gesagt ja also
heute nacht auf jeden fall die fenster
zumachen
falls unser letztes video ist lassen
leichter kann man die maskerade heißt es
chlorgas es ist die gesamte besatzung
von dem verdammten not much kikisch
oxidischen wieder
[Musik]
aber
also wenn das jetzt raus bekommst du
einen kanal und ich würde sagen dass war
als stille nacht heilige nacht
die heizungskörper wärmt uns nachts
heiße nacht überquerte heute ist musik
schon ich werde euch der satz liegt ihm
nicht ins jugend fresse kriegt davon
jede schneeschieber natürlich die beste
mit chichewa und gabi huber
ballaballa jetzt kommt live für dich von
maria lahm nach deutsch
[Musik]
bilderserie dynamics nav man kann den
kredit kenne ich ja auch gerne noch
meinen linken fuß
ich habe wirklich keine art ist also ich
denke mal ein film technisch
pflegebetten business sondern doppelbett
oder wollen bisher zwei doppelbetten
sind zum sex geeignet weil irgendwas
werden
der original satz war verständlich der
heute forum fiktiv es könnte also gar
nicht mal so schwarz für dich die
eigentlich hatte er schon wieder schauen
weil also mechanisch kannst du
wahrscheinlich nicht glaube ich weiß
jetzt was es ist es gleich jedoch doch
dann hast du überhaupt geschaut und
gesagt ich schon dabei wenn ich es jetzt
habe ich gewonnen und geht wird es wohl
wieder ins boot verlassen durfte zweimal
das passt du kennst an ihren besetzt
werk mal in chinesisch traditionell als
optiker als ob sechs wörter einfach
sechs schriftzeichen sein blühen dann
hätten wir gerne mal tee sich ach du
scheiße dann hätten wir gerne mal hat
schick selbst gestellt dann hätten wir
jetzt gerne aber jetzt darüber bleiben
sie die nacht im fenster die nach
fenster muss geschlossen bleiben das
heute nach das fenster geschlossen
ursprünglich war es heute nacht bleiben
die fenster geschlossen
sollte das wasser heutigen video da
waren einige folgte sachen dabei 30
gefallen hat last auf jeden fall einen
fuß in den kommentaren